maybe sometimes I look back to Titan and
where we got a little we got a little
squirrely under the weight of this giant
idea we were chasing everyone starts
going off to their own camps and
building their own part and just trying
to you know protect the you know that
the part of it that they can be uniquely
responsible for and we frayed a little
bit and we lost that that space where
we're so strong right where we pull it
back together and everyone shares a
little bit of the big picture and in so
many ways overwatch is from from its
themes to its game played like
everything about this project whether
that's visible to the end-user or not is
our story it is it is a redemption story
we needed this as people
you
action quake was one of the greatest
mods of all time there was a split what
was going to become of the action quake
community and it was action half-life
and counter-strike
before Jeff Goodman who's Arizona
working on overwatch he and actually and
I were actually in a team fortress clan
we didn't even like know each we didn't
even know each other
I think we had a self expectation of
like is this the kind of company we are
we the MMO company so I think there was
a lot of pressure that we put on
ourselves to want to deliver something a
lot like Wow and another Wow and it led
us down strange paths
hello and welcome to a three-part video
series about blizzards latest video game
overwatch a first-person multiplayer
shooter which comes out on PC and
consoles in early May my name is Daniel
Dwyer and I love online shooters more
specifically I love PC online shooters
my formative years were spent playing
games like quake Unreal Tournament team
fortress and counter-strike and I still
dabble today recently trying at the doom
beta and epics new UT but also found a
blizzard estudio on the complete
opposite side of the PC gaming spectrum
a studio which dominated the real-time
strategy isometric role-playing and
massively multiplayer online Jean Rah's
Blizzard made great games so great they
tend to even attract people who don't
necessarily play that genre I mean world
of warcraft was where i spent most of my
college years
well thereand dust2 but in recent months
i've been enjoying a lot of overwatch a
game I first played at Blizzcon 2014
it's not a long-running on-and-off
closed beta since late last year so and
given the opportunity to travel down to
blizzards headquarters a few weeks ago I
jumped at the chance you see over
watches more than Blizzard trying to
invade a new genre it's more than an
attempt to bring back classic
class-based shooters of old it's also
the child of lizards biggest game they
never made a game which a substantial
portion of blizzards spent years working
on before went dark and was eventually
canceled a game we know almost nothing
concrete about a game known as Titan so
to fully tell the story of overwatch
where it came from and why it's chosen
as blizzards first new IP in 17 years we
have to first tell the story of a group
of people who spend years of their lives
on a game nobody has ever seen a modest
group of savvy designers who years
earlier combined to create one of the
biggest video games of all time
my first project I worked on at Blizzard
was Justice League Task Force
I'd never animated a thing in my life
and the but the boss saw that I could I
could draw that there was something
there and in this 19 year old Punk and
so they stuck me on learning deluxe
animator which was a pretty simplistic
program back in the day where you
animate four frames at a time and it was
super fun and I learned a lot and it
wasn't really until about a year later
after I got hired
we were really sparking the ideas for
Warcraft 2 and I fired up and went you
know what you know I got this idea for a
story and the boss heard me out and as
fate would have it or whatever he took a
chance another chance on me and let me
write Warcraft 2 and it's been kind of
crazy crazy journey ever since yeah you
sort of have your finger prints and
essentially like if not all most of
blizzards games since since the early
90s for good or ill I didn't know much
about Blizzard before I joined here
which is super bizarre I was more into
the FPS community I had known a lot
about it and quake and doom and I had
followed all those games and I was very
into mod making for you know half-life
and in games like that they hired to
quit quest designers to start at the
exact same time it was me and a
gentleman named Pat Nagel Pat and I
literally started on the same day and
shared an office and together we
designed the quest system along with
guys like Eric Dodds and Alan Adam
Alan's one of the founders of Blizzard
Eric is the game director on hearthstone
our little group designed the quest
system on World of Warcraft and then in
the early days when we first started we
split up Pat did Elwynn forest and I did
Westfall and Pat and I would just sit in
this like we sat back-to-back in the
office and we were always leaning it
like hey I'm trying this out what do you
think about that and it was really
together that we sort of came up with
the questing system in World of Warcraft
you guys were back to back just like
Westfall on the other part yeah exactly
and then there was a scary duskwood
river outside of
our office that we rarely cross stitches
it was in the other seat oh yeah and Pat
made stitches to it yeah that was his
quest I started on what was called the
dungeon team and the dungeon team was
primarily the people that would build
all the dungeons and cities in the world
I started on that I got to build some of
the dungeons in the game I built a bunch
of the original cities that were in the
game and I worked on it all the way
through all the way through ship and was
such a blast awesome to build Stallman
yeah I got a build Stormwind I guess um
I'll like hold on to that one until my
grave you know someone else they wanted
forward you know I did iron forge I did
a lot of the cities in there
Thunder Bluff iron forge Darnassus some
of the other guys did the Undercity and
so I was kind of a city guy what was it
like seeing storm wind like realized
them a film that was actually a kind of
a emotional moment for me it was two
years ago at Blizzcon the first time
storm wind just popped up onto the
screen I kind of teared up a little bit
it was it's kind of it's amazing to see
some of the work that you've done put
into another medium and other people use
it and after about a minute though
everything changed and I started to get
a little embarrassed and critical of it
and I was pointing to things in the
trailer because I watch it a number of
times going I can't believe they
actually used this thing that I put in
there and I've never really liked it but
hopefully I'm the only one thinking that
did a lot of the initial raid bosses
starting with like onyxia I did a
Blackwing Lair I look like I'm layer and
then throughout that I just continued on
and did ton of raid bosses and became
sort of the the encounter team that
started the encounter team so I haven't
been on the team a while now and it's
obviously grown significantly in the hit
there's a lot more to the world but back
then it was looks like it was four of us
at that at the time kind of popular in
the whole world it's a little bit crazy
but it was a different time but it was
it was a lot of fun were you part of the
team that was working on
that actually went over water yeah I was
part of that initial team I mean that at
that point I had been working a while
for a really long time and I kind of
jumped at the opportunity to try
something new and yeah I was a lot of it
was a lot of fun for a while
in world of warcraft blizzard created
one of the largest most profitable and
most beloved game series ever made a
game with a fanbase of millions over a
decade later a game with a multi-million
dollar movie coming out later this year
so when it came to Blizzard deciding
what their next project should be they
gathered many of those same leaders and
set their sights on a new adventure with
all the success of World of Warcraft
it's no wonder their sites were aimed
high I think we were feeling the success
and thinking like oh well we we could
turn around and do another one of those
how hard was it say has anyone remember
how rough it was the first time but for
all that the 10,000 you know wheels you
need to reinvent just to make one of
these work and maybe there was a little
bit of you know pridefulness and
thinking that we just turned right
around and rock one out lizard doesn't
talk about Titan it's notorious for
being a no-go area during interviews and
when you can see there they're launching
overwatch next month you can't blame
them for not wanting to show us the
skeletons in their closets so what if
anything we know about this game comes
from rumor and uncredited sources we
know it was an MMO it was possibly a
multiverse or multi-genre game it was
larger in scope than world of warcraft
and a lot of Blizzard was working on it
in fact for my time talking to the
overwatch team it was clear that the
majority of them had worked on Titan so
I was interested to find out what
happened that pushed all of these
talented people off of Titan and on to
overwatch maybe sometimes I look back to
Titan and where we got a little we got a
little squirrely under the weight of
this giant idea we were chasing is that
we in some ways lost some connectivity
with each other and everyone starts
going off to their own camps and build
in their own part and just trying to you
know protect the you know the part of it
that they can be uniquely responsible
for and there was some wee frayed a
little bit and we lost that that space
where we're so strong right where we
pull it back together and everyone
shares a little bit of the big picture I
talked to our I didn't talk I was out of
press event
at Blizzcon 2014 where yourself and
Chris sort of briefly talked about the
passion that sort of came from Titan was
sort of funneled into a board can you
talk about that sort of timeframe like
where overwatch existed and that was it
split off from Ty nor was it like its
own like separate project that then
everyone went okay we're working on this
thing it was a little bit of both so
overwatch is its own separate thing but
the team that was working on Titan which
was a very large team a very large
project basically we shrunk down when
Titan was cancelled we decided we're
going to take a smaller group of people
and rethink what we could do you know
let's think about doing something very
different
the thing that was super special about
that is you had a really amazing group
that was working on Titan they're really
talented individuals but we failed
horrific aliy and in every way we failed
in sort of every way a project can fail
and it was devastating you had these
people who either came from other
companies or came from within blizzard
and were used to working on games that
were very successful like a World of
Warcraft for example and to go through
such a complete and utter failure is
very hard for people who are used to
experiencing success and kind of having
that that level of confidence just be
shattered is kind of shocking I think
when at the point at which you know we
we I would I say it shut Titan off
we were pretty low and and being very
honest about we weren't used to feeling
that way you know we had had so much
good luck and failing was rough and it
tested us in ways that we had not been
tested before and that's why as we
attempted to regroup and build a new
idea we decided to do it in very
different ways and kind of account for
the things that might have led us down
those weirder paths with the with the
previous MMO idea we had to pull
together we had to take an honest naked
audit of what got us there and how we
want to work going forward how we're
going to look at each other and treat
each other and invest in each other
regardless of what we made
next it was the most bonding moment for
this group because it it was um kind of
a crisis of confidence and identity
where you start to ask yourselves you
know did we lose it do we not know who
we are anymore are we not capable of
making a great game anymore so when we
took that smaller group and said hey
what do you guys want to do or what do
you guys really believe in we saw it as
a last chance you know we kind of used
the phrase often you're only good as
your you're only as good as your last
game and so you don't get like
big-headed like oh yeah I back in you
know for me like in 2008 I worked on
World of Warcraft well guess what that
was in 2008 you know my most recent game
was an utter failure called Titan that
got canceled you know what can I do next
to prove that that's not who I am in the
years during Titans development video
game dev sizes exploded Studios like
Ubisoft EA and even blizzards parent
company Activision have made teams of
thousands commonplace but Titan this
massive idea which had multiple teams
working on it never came together for
Blizzard so I guess there are two things
a studio can do at that point push on
and try and fix the problems with more
time energy and money or call it quits
and try and refocus their efforts this
decision was a very real moment for the
Titan team what are we really doing I
would just selling product you know you
know for a corporation like I guess
that's a part of it but we're artists
and craftsmen and technologists and you
know writers and poets and all these
other things like coming together to
build something that's greater than any
of us could have achieved on our own
that has always been the story of Wizard
it and when we recognize that and come
back to that very simple stance as we
look around at each other that is always
where we've been strongest not worrying
about the scale of the business not
worrying about the scale and specificity
of the video game we're trying to build
for 12 different genius reasons it's
coming back to people what are we
prepared to spend the next five years of
our lives on together it was almost like
an embarrassment you know and you wanted
to say to the company because here you
have these great projects like you know
Starcraft here's the storm hearthstone
World of Warcraft
and then you're sitting on the smoking
pile of the cancelled project and and
nobody said a word everybody was super
supportive to us but I think there was
like this inward embarrassment of like
now we need to prove that we're worthy
of being at Blizzard too and we can make
something that makes the company proud
as well so yeah it was it was a trying
period of time and there was a lot of
pressure but it helped Forge us in a lot
of ways I think the need to proof
ourselves was was really really big
following Titan to ourselves making
video games takes time it takes years
and for dozens of people likely hundreds
at the peak of titans development that
was years down the drain some of the
overwatch team haven't shipped a game in
a decade some of the team came to
Blizzard years ago and it's still yet to
ship a game at the studio this was a
team heavily scarred by years of work
that nobody ever saw which is why when
it came to overwatch you can understand
why they kept their cards so close to
the chest nobody ever saw footage of
overwatch before it was announced at
Blizzcon 2014 in our next two videos
we'll explore what happened during those
years but the outside world didn't get a
sniff of what this game was until Chris
Metzen took to the stage at the Anaheim
Convention Center and showed it to the
world I was actually in the crowd that
day covering the event for GameSpot
eager to see if the rumors were true
that Blizzard were set to announce their
first new IP in 17 years but for the
overwatch team many of whom were part of
the Titan team who lined the first few
rows of this audience of thousands this
was much more it was the first time the
world would actually see their work it
was proof that unlike Titan overwatch
was real
where were you when when that happened
when oh man I was bawling my eyes out in
the front row you're not the first
person to say that yeah it was really
emotional like I think most of the team
was near the front of the stage just
watching a Jeff and Chris unveil the
game and it was it was incredible I was
like
that one of the highlights of my career
that was that was one of the most
amazing moments ever in my career and
I've been doing this here you know 22
plus years I walked out and I was so
excited to share this thing with the
world I was I was trying to hopefully do
a good job and set it up really well and
a thousand things run through my head
and I look out it makes me emotional now
I'm a very sensitive you know kind of
emotional Irish dude and so a mint it's
hard for me too it's hard for me to
contain my excitement passion whatever
and I remember looking out I'm like this
is going okay so far
you know about to do the thing and I see
I can't remember who it was anymore but
just like if one section back a couple
familiar faces of you know my team for
brothers and sisters sitting there and
everybody's just so just so owning the
moment together and it's like I almost
started crying you know like oh because
is it as excited as I was to tell the
world about overwatch and as excited as
I am about overwatch I was so overjoyed
for my friends that we had weather one
kid in that room liked it or not didn't
matter is that we've built this thing
together we pulled our boots back on
after you know kind of fallen in the
dust you know a few short years before
and we pulled it together and we did a
good job for each other and we built
this idea that just delights us in a
stupid way
the thing that flashed in my head is
like we're back back from where I don't
know but just that that feeling of like
we did it we climbed the mountain
over watch born from the ashes of Titan
is an entirely different beast from
whatever game that game was and in the
next two videos in this series we'll
fill in the blanks on those years
Blizzard went underground we'll explore
the shooters at Blizzard mind
inspiration from and learned had a team
designed over watches maps modes and
heroes in fact here's one last little
snippet that nicely ties it two together
we don't know much about how much of
Titan made its way into overwatch but we
did learn one thing one of its lead
heroes staring us in the face this whole
time like from the very beginning like
when this when this entire thing started
we knew we were doing tracer right what
is it about tracer that was so because a
lot of people have said that I've said
the tracer is like one of the first
characters but tracer actually seems
like one of the more unique characters
on the way I think it was um and this
goes back to Titan there's a character
had the abilities that like tracer has
don't worry loves Cavalry's it
you